i'm busy phillips and i play summer and
i'm paula pal
and i play gloria and i'm renee lee
scolsberry and i play
wiki hi i'm sara bareilles and i play
dawn
in the new hit peacock series girls five
ever
we're here with buzzfeed and we are
going to play a little quiz
to find out which iconic girl band
we belong in
[Music]
okay first how would your bffs
describe your vibe bold vibrant
flirty dazzling eclectic
or chill oh my gosh is there a d
all of the above i'll say vibrant i
think
i would choose bold i try to make like
courageous choices in a bold way but
also i like puzzles and like watching tv
and stuff
i would say they absolutely would
describe me as eclectic
okay i did vibrant because you know i
agree with that
lots of color choose a song to belt out
at karaoke
dancing queen by abba savage by megan
the salient
watermelon sugar by harry styles bad guy
by billy eilish come on eileen
or i want to dance with somebody by
whitney houston i mean mine is a
no-brainer obviously
i'm doing watermelon sugar by harry mine
would be between that
and savage because sometimes i like to
you know
i'm a couple inches in on the wine i
like to
get low and shake my big flap
you like to pop it i do i like to pop it
how do you not
choose i want to dance with somebody but
i think right now it would be bad guy
billy eilish i knew you're gonna be
really eyelash
i've been on a little bit of a billy
eyelash kick she's got a song out
she's doing these cool new photographs i
really like i love her artistry
i feel like she's been so much of the
soundtrack for this last year um in a
way that's been really life-saving so i
understand that choice
and i'm still gonna say i wanna dance
with somebody i just felt like you know
growing up as a singer
i felt like if i could sing what
whitney's saying i might have a shot
that is the song i wanna hear you sing
on this list choose an
iconic lyric to use as your next
instagram
caption if i was you i want to be me too
by meghan trainor okay ladies now let's
get in formation
beyonce a scrub is a guy that can't get
no love from me
tlc darling i'm a nightmare dressed like
a daydream
taylor swift hello it's me
adele no i'm not a snack at all look
baby on the whole damn
meal oh my god it's so hard they're all
so
you just want them all i know all and
you know what you gotta you gotta post
every day so i would just i would just
take them off
no i'm not a stack at all look baby i'm
the whole damn
meal i think i would choose okay ladies
now let's get in formation
yes i feel like especially as we're on
the verge
of releasing the show i'm in a readying
stance
in a way i mean i'm gonna go with lizza
she's just all
head to toe empowerment yeah i mean i'm
probably doing hello it's me
and you're not gonna elaborate no guys
hi it's me
here i am pick a musical legend to
collab with
britney spears elton john janet jackson
madonna lady gaga or
sir paul mccartney elton i saw him only
once perform live and i cried through
the entire thing and my friend was like
i thought we were supposed to be
enjoying this and i'm like
i'm enjoying this i'm going with elton
as well
my karaoke jam for real has often been
any number of elton john songs i got one
when i started working with you
missy yeah okay right it's kind of the
alton for me
i got to sing with him one time he's
saying myself with me
and he came out in like a sequence
blazer and he's got his like initials on
the back he's like everything
uh somebody just told me a story about
paul mccartney that is going to make me
choose him somebody was
was playing with him i think and they
were like freaking out because
they were with paul mccartney and he
said something along the lines of
it's easy it works it works if it
doesn't it doesn't i have to go with
paul mccartney and this just kind of
very casual
chill attitude towards putting more
music into the world
pick a show to binge watch during your
down time
grey's anatomy law and order svu the
circle
30 rock one division or this is us
i am going to say law and order svu did
you hear that they were shooting law and
order svu next door to
my house here in new york i was coming
home from dinner in an
uber i had had a glass of wine and they
were on a break and
marishka was getting her makeup touched
up the middle of covet i'm wearing a
mask it's totally out of context i've
met marishka hargitay exactly one time
nine years ago i believe it is the house
directly next door i'm like
marishka hi it's me
busy i don't know what i was thinking
but i couldn't help it because it was
just so exciting to see them filming
anyway i choose if i had seen the svu
program being shot i think i would have
just gone down there and started loading
up a bunch of boxes into the back of a
truck and been one of the witnesses of
something it whether it was written into
the script or not i'd just be like yeah
i know the
guy he gets rough sometimes i'm not
gonna lie about it they're all so good
i would pick 30 rock i have not seen
every episode of 30 rock and i would
love
to watch that that woman that powerful
woman you know show me how it's done
so when we get a season two i'm i'm even
more of the whole meal you know what i'm
saying
i think yeah 30 rock for me is like
comfort food
and it's so smart and it's so dense so i
could just watch that over and over and
over
okay and finally last question pick your
favorite 90s trend we've got frosted
tips
slip dresses track suits
tiny sunglasses funky patterns
and everything grunge oh god this is so
hard for me because i love
everything grunge but i also love funky
patterns i
am gonna say funky patterns no i like
funky patterns but i have to say
mine is for sure track suits and the
fact that track suits are back
is making me very happy because i like
track suits with funky patterns
i'd pick the track suits it's comfort
wear for cobin
you know as well it's good for airplanes
you could sleep in planes
you can dress it up for me honestly it's
everything grunge
the t-shirts the horses t-shirts the
flannels
i loved it too i live dirty the drug use
there's a lot of things i'm really
really passionate about
oh nice girls is that spice girls
you'd definitely be in the spice girls
you're super fun flirting have a bit of
mischievous side
you have a magnetic personality and
light up every room you enter
people just can't get enough of you but
it is really true that i would i would
describe you like that
just take flirty out i'm not flirty guys
i don't have any gain
i mean i need game when i'm in the home
depot and i need to like get
something ordered earlier than it's
supposed to come you know and i'll throw
my hair around a little bit
i'm a little mixed you're fun
adventurous and super chill
sometimes people underestimate you but
you always prove that you are indeed a
force to be reckoned with you have a bit
of an edgier side and that's what makes
you so unique
i'm fifth harmony you're fierce
charismatic and a total goof that is so
true
you love to make people laugh and are
typically the funniest one in the room
amen you're like a burst of sunshine and
people just love whenever you're around
oh i'm in destiny's child you'd
definitely be in destiny's child you're
bold
ambitious and oh so dazzling you're
constantly inspiring others and you
never fail to put a smile on people's
faces
oh that's true one of a kind that's true
you are one of a kind i do not know
anyone else like you busy
and i'm glad that our paths crossed yeah
ew
me five emma
you